how has the book been received here over
in the UK well it is an explosive Memoir
we were promised an autobiography that
was raw and unflinching it has
absolutely delivered and have penguin
got their dollars worth out of Prince
Harry absolutely I mean Jaws really are
on the ground over here in the UK and in
terms of the royal family the palace are
keeping a dignified silence um they're
really not briefing about this there is
still no comment out of Kensington
Palace and out of Buckingham Palace but
the repercussions of of Harry's
autobiography of the things that he said
and are clearly being felt and the King
well I think he simply can't believe
what his youngest son has done William
is said to be privately seething and and
devastated by his brother and what he
has done in this autobiography but he's
also incredibly angry at the level of
detail which his brother has shared in
this book now the king invited Harry and
Megan to Sandringham for Christmas they
refused that invitation the King has
made a real point of extending an olive
branch to the couple
um and I think knowing just how damaging
this book was going to be for the royal
family Harry and Megan made that
decision to stay away over Christmas how
would your mom feel about your
relationship with your brother now
I think she would be
I think she would be sad that the family
mutter is never complained never explain
but it's just a motto and it doesn't
really hold there's a lot of complaining
and a lot of explaining and private
being done in through leagues through
leaks Prince Harry has given a number of
interviews ahead of the release of his
autobiography and he speaks about
wanting to reconcile with his family he
talks about the door being open but I
think the feeling is that actually he's
made sure that door has been firmly
slammed shut the idea of any
reconciliation seems almost Unthinkable
given what he has said given the very
personal nature of these attacks because
that's what they are they are verbal
attacks on members of the royal family
and not just any member of the royal
family his father his brother his
mother-in-law his sister-in-law no one
is really spared in spare
foreign
[Music]